have you uh have you heard from
bam I have not and the reason why is
because um I had to to create some
healthy
boundaries right
um in the last cuz he just celebrated 60
days yeah um there got to a point at the
end where you know when we were talking
and I don't think he was in a good he
wasn't in a good place then he was like
really spewing this hateful stuff and
I'm like this this behavior isn't
acceptable to me like I I I accept where
he is as a human being but I don't need
to show up for that to take that okay
for the record did you crash his car
absolutely you did 100% okay and oh is
is is he going off about the car no no I
just remember back in the day and I just
never heard you address that but I was
wondering I was like uh I absolutely did
um and he he easily what he says is true
he could have reported the car stolen to
the insurance company and got reimbursed
he did not I didn't go to jail he ate
that cost um but without me having to
make this like a [__] it I mean I'll
just say it um on the 28th of every
month Phil receives a check from me from
Financial amounts which has been
actively happening now I'd say for the
past two years or maybe three good for
you yeah that's so but that's not
something that I needed to you know we
cut that out if you want to cut it out I
was just trying to be funny and it
turned into the serious thing it's
totally cool um and I really don't care
either way but I'd see people say that
and they come and I took a note and
lesson from you which I do a lot um
where I really
stopped buying into social media I
stopped reading the comments I stopped
letting because I saw you do that yeah
dude I I did my best to avoid the
comments man so now I'm at the point
where I'm trying to practice like one
hour a day social media
my Vinnie now you got me got me worried
like what no dude all good do
you he really sold that
yeah um so uh so what bam reaches out to
you and you don't pick up the phone or
no I I had to block him oh wow um just
because at that time when I did that he
was like really not exhibiting nice
behaviors this is recently right he had
a fair recent rant on on Novak this
probably like four months ago is sounds
about right um but what I do believe is
true now is that he is probably doing
the best that I've seen him do in a long
time and the reason why is his skating I
can tell when he's like not just like
standing on a board get a shot of me I
saw that like that uh it was it wasn't a
melon it was but it was
just you know it's like alcoholics like
you whatever you say doesn't matter
right but like your behaviors will tell
me exactly how you're living his
skateboarding I can tell when he's like
thoroughly sincerely skating and he only
does that when he's doing better the
last time I saw him do that was when he
was filming the vice thing in Spain with
Winkle that was he's he's back there
again so he looks good you know he looks
good on his social media here's the
crazy thing is that uh two days ago my
buddy Darby Allen who the wrestler for
aew and he's just a rad skater A rad guy
the guy who went down the halfpipe in a
body bag yeah yeah the qu the vert wall
quarter pipe at Baker um he's yeah I I
love that guy and he's like pretty tight
with bam came he came over and he's
skating the ramp a couple days ago I was
like hey man I lost touch with bam you
know like I I don't have a number for
him I don't anything you know but like
but but I want bam to see my ramp dude
can you like just text him this clip
that I just uh shot of you skating just
texted to Bam and uh Derby let me know
that bam got back to him and he said uh
he bam asked was steo talking [__] about
me and D Derby said no he wasn't he just
wants you to skate his ramp something
like that and uh I'm glad man I got I'm
not I'm not here to talk [__] I I mean
right now so ironically enough his
girlfriend this girlfriend that he has
who seems to be in inciting some kind of
motivation in him uh messaged me the
other day she dm' me and she said this
is like three days ago and she's like um
I just want you to know I've never met
you it's nice to meet you I don't know
what your past looks like but um bam is
like you know he he misses you and he
talks about you often and and he smiles
when conversations come up about you you
know and and that's nice yeah I don't I
don't think that I will like um want
to re entertain like a I'll no who the
[__] am I to say that I'll show up for
him whenever like he did for me um and
hopefully it will take somewhere along
the line yeah the craziest part of why I
brought up Darby Allen
is that he told me Bam's got his alcohol
monitor bracelet off I was shot he's got
it off and he isn't ex I I that's crazy
I would have bet my I even said I bet my
sobriety when that bracelet comes off
he's right back to where he left off and
when I found that out I would just I was
like wow things are changing maybe right
and and I I would say thank God for this
this court case thank God for this
criminal court case because I think bam
is legitimately terrified of getting
wasted and ending up in jail because of
it I've seen a lot of handcuffs create
sobriety for people Big Time divinely
inconvenienced yeah it's all it's all
also like you know family judge well
it's like when the family stops enabling
that's when you usually get sober you
know or when like you're closest friends
so of course like a a lawsuit from Jess
like you I mean it's a tough decision to
make if you're Jess but you have to do
that kind of [__] sometimes not a lot of
say criminal charges what's the
difference one is uh well yeah what is
the difference I mean the criminal
courts deal with with freedom and civil
courts deal with uh money
H like well regardless because I
remember I was telling the story like
when I heard on L line Dr Drew and he
was like dude like if you have a family
member that's a drunk and he keeps
driving call the cops on him get him
arrested have him go to jail that's
where I'm at and a lot of people are
like I would never [__] do that to my
it's like right bro I mean at the you
know 20 30th time like [__] that guy
even if he's my brother like he's going
to hurt somebody and you can't just sit
there and watch whatever the case may be
you know and um I I I had a call with a
with a lady the other day I her I used
to work with her son and and um the son
wasn't responding to the text and so I
texted his mom and I was like hey have
you heard from so and so and she's like
oh he's in another rehab and I you know
she was just venting and venting and I
said you ever thought about doing alanon
they do not want to [__] hear about
alanon and it's like uh it's just a
strange thing like like they can't they
have this rationalization in their head
that you know I would never do that to
my son or i' never like it's my baby I
don't want to it's like but you baby
them you bury them yeah absolutely
absolutely I'm a big fan of things
getting bad right cuz for me things had
to get really bad before they got really
good and I I adopted that mentality from
my sponsor my first sponsor I was at the
end and I was in a bad way and I was
stranded at the airport and I like was
really contemplating suicide I had come
up with a plan and I I texted uh my
sponsor and I said dude I'm going to
like kill myself this is I can't do it
and his response was a picture of a
poppy
plant you know like and he always said
to me you never get between an alcoholic
and their bottom ever ever ever ever and
and that for me my experience states
that I had to have repercussions for my
actions do you like shopping on Amazon I
do and good news is sto's butt wipes for
your butthole are available on Amazon
and if you want a real bundle of a deal
you can get sto's hot sauce for your
butthole plus sto's butthole destroyer
and steo butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right
now yeah dude